looks like the Batman may have a whole
lot of villainous trouble to deal with
when the Dark Knight Returns a fresh
report from week out this cupboard has
suggested that Robert Pattinson version
of the Caped Crusader will face no fewer
than six villains in his first solo
outing the penguin the Riddler
Catwoman two-face Firefly and the Mad
Hatter in its coverage of the Batman the
outlet is previously reported that the
Riddler the penguin
Catwoman toupees scarecrow and Bane have
all been under consideration for a part
in the movie story with potentially all
six of them showing up at the same time
according to the more recent report
however those last two have been subbed
out in favor of some slightly more
obscure characters before we go on
though let's note that a lot can change
behind the scenes during the development
of a movie especially this particular
movie nothing is certain until it's
certain and any rumors swirling around
this project ought to be taken with a
bunch of grains of you-know-what
could you pass the salt of the two new
additions to the movies potential rogues
gallery
Firefly seems like the best fit for the
noir style narrative that writer
director Matt Reeves reportedly has in
mind for the film the character first
appeared way back in 1952 and Detective
Comics number 184 an expert in
pyrotechnics who plied his trade in the
motion picture industry Garfield lynns
found himself mired in poverty when work
dried up like so many of Gotham's
destitute citizens he soon turned to a
life of crime drawing the attention of
Batman and Robin who captured him during
a robbery attempt in later stories Lin's
enacted his revenge by lashing out with
acts of arson and soon took quite a
liking to it always on the hunt for
bigger and bigger targets he eventually
set fire to a chemical factory and
succumbed to the flames himself he
survived the blaze but was left covered
in severe burns inexplicably Lin's
continued on with his new line of work
making himself a special fire resistant
suit and an array of new weapons before
taking on the guise of the supervillain
Firefly according to we got this
coverage report an early production
document indicates that lanes backstory
will possibly be revised to make him a
man in his 20s who grew up orphaned
before embarking on a fiery rampage
against the privileged people of Gotham
which could make for an interesting
parallel with Batman's own backstory
the Mad Hatter's history stretches even
further back in DC Laura all the way to
his first appearance in 1948 Batman
number 49 first portrayed is a common
criminal with an unusual affinity for
his namesake
Jervis Tetch has since been shown to
possess a high degree of skill and
electrical engineering which he uses to
produce his signature devices
mind-controlling hats as for the other
bad guys said to be on tap for the
Batman any of them could be solid
choices just so long as they're done
properly the penguin and the Riddler are
two iconic villains whose previous big
screen appearances tended toward the
garish and comedic and while two-face
was certainly done justice by Aaron
Eckhart's performance in The Dark Knight
many fans felt that the character was
given too little screen time as for
Catwoman well whoever ends up taking
that role has some mighty boots to fill
however it all shakes out it's important
to remember that none of this is
confirmed and those characters could
easily be swapped out or cut all
together before the Batman's final
shooting script is in place after all
front-loading a film with six villains
seems mighty ambitious and it's not like
superhero movies haven't struggled to
juggle bad guys in the past I know all
these guys come from whatever course
Reeves does choose to take fans will
just have to have faith in his talent
and hope that the director can deliver
both the Batman we need and the Batman
we deserve check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite comic book
movies are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]